hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to me sound now we got
a boot disk and what a boot disk means
is that I can go back to the lab and I'm
able to actually do the thing that it
wanted me to do when I first got there
and that I saw before I got mauled to
death by the shadowy creature behind the
bosses or the tubes whatever you want to
climb the to be things
hey I probably could have gone the other
way but it would have been fine whatever
not big lady let's go I don't know
please put in password I okay we're in
world was I supposed to find a password
I mean is this the principal secret
password that I'm supposed to know
somehow maybe I could just go and ask
him what a stupid all right whatever
okay let me think back to all the
numbers that I've seen and heard
throughout this game oh wait I haven't
seen any I okay alrighty then oh wait
god damn it was the phone son of a [ __ ]
ah the stupid phone okay so there is a
sign there's a sign over there right
here
posters ranking the coolest students of
2a so in classroom to a there's these
ass bags now what I noticed when I
looked at this before in the last
episode when I cut out is that April May
June so fear Octavian novella deca
you know those are all names relating to
month but the first three don't bruno
goldman nick verde and train waar don't
the kind of difference so in to a I'm
gonna take another picture of this with
modern technology I anything is possible
I'm gonna take another picture of this
so I can remember and I'm gonna go to to
a I'm gonna try to figure it out okay
all right okay all right okay all right
I'm a puzzle solving genius okay
okay so 2a would be there's a class 2a
okay so somewhere in here are their
names
Sarah lists is there like something I
could know
is there a reason any of this is there
it's just part of a code is this like oh
oh I get it I get it I get it I get it I
get it I get it I get it
I was looking at the last names are
colors but their colors in various
language like Verde is green in Spanish
I don't know what train waar is but
there are the color that coordinates
with the color of the boot thingy is in
association with whatever the hell's
going on but I'm gonna be able to find
it because I have it right here the
puzzle is nice so I'm gonna be god
that's creepy okay so I'm gonna be able
to get this ah okay okay then uh orange
oh he could orange be gold because if
Bruno Goldman is gold and that means
it'd be one now train waar is copper
which is kind of that color of brown and
it'd be three now April red is for May
white is 5 but deca gray is 10 but I'm
guessing that 10 has the little one
scrubbed down on it so he's PI zero dad
son of a [ __ ] unless grey was silver
which would mean it would be 2 so maybe
that was also it we try that okay Oh bag
ah poopy poopy in my pants I thought I
had this okay let's assume that the
first three have almost nothing to do
with this orange is Saphira ochre Oh
gray which might be orange in some
strange fashion the brown one is
Octavian bronze
red is obviously April red may wipe and
then deca gray yes I did it I oh hello
okay I see you oh no you had to wait so
scary okay so now get this I did it I
did it okay okay okay so it's fine cuz I
got more it's the same damn thing okay
so it's like black trained warned war
might mean black so three Bruno Goldman
Nikki fared a Azur is blue and then
violet is nine yes I am genius I found
me cells hard alright I've got a heart
on me so now I can go sacrifice him all
yay okay so is there anything else that
I need to do before I start just
chucking body part let me go save an
actual save before I do this before I
start burning these old body parts so
something else that I can do okay
alright okay I'm going for it I really
don't think there's anything else that I
need to do unless there's some clue that
maybe miss lady has I'm just gonna
double check six items and that's it
okay that's the only other thing
correctly I did not get the password of
the principal but I don't know what else
I would do with that so I'm gonna assume
that I'm good right I'm good I mean I'm
just operating on the assumption that
there are multiple endings to this game
now I don't know if there are but that's
what I'm assuming
there also is one gravestone that isn't
lit either way it doesn't matter doesn't
matter I got this I got this
oh yeah hey Goethe all right yes
all the pots were offered but nothing
happens why isn't anything happening
so do I need to do something what do I
need to do what is it what else is there
to do
I've already been everywhere I've
already discovered everything I've
already gotten all the body parts do I
need to fill out like the last huh I did
everything you asked of me this alleles
in here the else Oh hmm
I found all yo oh that's odd why didn't
that undo the curse
maybe mr. Oni Kawara know something okay
so I gotta talk to the creepy principal
so he can tell me exactly what I did
wrong all right okay he would know
something wouldn't he being the sneaky
son of a [ __ ] that he is yeah I see you
sacrificed a body of your time however
this alone doesn't seem to have undone
the curse her leand alive Zagar eyes
live sacrifice did you see the red
tombstones in the abyss the spirits of
the ones whose names are there must be
sacrificed for free hers now for
tombstone so there must be four names
three of them have already had names
engraved in them there's just one left
someone must be the Last Sacrifice then
all I Samantha will have my name written
on that grave that is impossible
assume stones are tools of a hatred
surely one who was not any resentment
could not carve their name there you set
out to save her she could not hate you
there are others still alive think well
on who must be the sacrifice someone who
Misao hates
hmm all right okay all right
ah Samantha I might be a little bit
crazy but I wouldn't say okay what am I
saying here so I'm gonna guess wait a
minute
good I'm guessing it's gonna be Toma I
can't think of anybody left but Toma
that me Sal would have a grudge against
oh my god right here right now right
here right now ah
and again the principal you know it's a
tough equation and this might be what
gets the moldable endings
I would imagine Toma then again what is
Toma really done I think I think I think
here's my logic okay
so the green air dude he got hit by the
car and in the car was a body part he
died body Heart Association maybe not
teacher had a body why did he have a
body part cuz he had a hand in killing
her that's why my logic is infallible
what is it it could still affect maybe
me so I oughta grunge on him because he
didn't listen to her so I kill him oh
here we go good even if he's badly hurt
I can't possibly kill him barehanded
he's something to you oh I'll bat him in
the back of the head yes of course I
save I'm gonna make sure that I saved
before I actually do this Oh bear with
me wakey wakey eggs and batty
hibbett act the blood won't stop sir
it's alright you'll be relieved soon
okay alrighty then well since that's all
for that one I'm glad answer with
justice has surely been dealt with
I believe okay all right okay all right
okay all right okay all right okay
Oh me Sal thank you for finding me wait
don't go be Sal itoma I heard from the
glasses chick you've done everything
what happened Misao she thanked me I'm
sure it's fine now so then the curse is
gone school back to normal right
yay it's getting bright out
Thoma let's go outside okay
this is the classroom is everything back
to normal huh missa missa dah dah dah
dah dah can't you see me
oh oh
listen everybody I got big news I think
you'll agree this one's a lie wasn't it
how'd you sure you know cut the crap and
tell us who the hell one of the girls
here likes toma huh you confessing to me
you wish it was me
it's none other than the simple girl who
never stands out Misao oh oh really
no ah hi
look Thomas right over there confess
your undying love
dot dot dot all right I'll date you me
Sal huh kind of had a crush on you
myself
DOMA huh Toma are you for real
Misao really you shut your trap it's
none of your business who I'm dating
Yoshino it straight numbers whose trade
your digits to those tasty dudes
okay I remember this was in the
classroom then too this is just before
me Sal went missing
oh did I do bad did I pick the wrong
choice
why did yo Shino tell well no matter
after all i'm tomans girlfriend now I
should thank you she know who Toma sent
me a text I like you Michelle you like
me too - Toma what he sounds in berry
how should I reply I want some of that
Dino Ferrari okay but look who's here
giggle oh no I did it wrong ah I love
you too Toma
oh I love you more than anyone in the
world well that's ok
oh I picked the wrong choice no this is
all my love you tell my lovey Lots my
heart melts like chocolate when you
cross my thoughts oh boy I chose wrong
ok Yoshi nose doing she must have snuck
a look at Thomas phone she's awful
you're Sheena I know you like Toma -
you're just jealous
it'll do you no good because dilma legs
me uh-oh
no stop it come on nobody's around Toma
I said I just Baxter teacher's Breton's
and for Nori's jeez tell me you pervert
aren't you the one who put me south text
on the blackboard of Tomei what I don't
know what you're saying
who else could have done it Ellis showed
you a tow me I didn't do anything
bling dumb huh yeah okey-dokey then
okay I'll figure out stuff now that Toma
likes you huh what are you looking at me
like that for Tom will never want you as
his girlfriend after this you she know
what [ __ ] laughs laughs jeez stop you
got some nerve me Sal what why don't you
see a lovely W and Tomar
what are you doing let go oh stop what I
doing to her I should take a picture
it'll last longer Oh
means oh I bet you know what will happen
if you tell you don't want that photo
getting out you better be a nice
obedient girl hey you really want me to
do this
oh yes give her lots of love
okay that's messed up
oh boy don't I'd come on out
mr. soda what are you doing in there get
back to your room it's long past lights
out sniff what is it Wow oh god it's
awful that's terrible
have you calmed down now yes did
something happen to you
please tell me whatever's troubling you
we can discuss it all you like huh
so teacher did listen to me so she
visited me the day before she went
missing
she had something to talk about but I
was so busy I didn't have the time to
listen to her I knew she was pained I
can't help but feel if I'd heard her out
she never would have left us why did
miss her so to lie about that is there
something you can't tell me teacher I I
had my heart broken I was being silly
shutting myself in the bathroom and
sobbing away over that it's not silly at
all I would lament the very same way all
night whenever I was rejected as my use
as he has youth you've experienced it
too mister soda hmm you find it odd it
would happen to me
well um since it you're so nice everyone
really likes you huh well I was an
irritating unpopular brat in my student
days I see irritating and unpopular
sounds a lot like me
absolutely not you're a very charming
girl teacher you're not like those other
idiot girls serious kind and calm I
adore girls like you teacher
me Sal on teacher like Oh Oh God
Oh your hands are so but oh god the hand
fetish
this isn't funny teacher oh they're both
[ __ ] all the teachers magnificently
worse mmm no good why are you running
away though you hate me you just praise
me as kind and lovable didn't you now
come here Oh
why why do you reject me why never do
that to me never okay this got dark
really quickly okay ah
oh okay so I was right
I just wasn't as right as I shine oh no
you are mine Oh Oh God
that Mister soda killed me Sal I I
didn't even know those awful things that
happened to me Sal me so I'm sorry Toma
he may have been ignorant but it's not
your fault miss out died so don't be so
hard on yourself
Samantha I've forgiven the name look the
schools back to normal the curse is
lifted me Sal I'm sure you're free of
your suffering uh
Wow okay that is all kinds of messed up
poor girl
this is the student council room right
really what I really should tell Oni
garlic oni Guevara Thanks
I wonder if he's it whoa hey what are
you standing around here for
um it's mr. Oneko whare there or you are
who uh you know the school student
council president well you see ah I'm
the student council president huh
there's no Oney Guara in the student
council oh okay
so what does that all mean
everything's gone back to the usual a
Yaka and yoshi she knows group are gone
so is mr. soda who killed me Sal but no
one seems to care for the people who
died in the other world erased from
existence I still remember my friends
though
and what Yoshino and mr. soda did to me
Sal it can't have never happened I
wonder if mr. Oni Guevara died in the
other world - I haven't seen Oni Guevara
is a blogger since I keep forgetting I
don't know what happened to them they
sure were strange people knew thou
say'st Franta pay attention I'm so sorry
giggle nice I was still missing no trace
of the parts of her I found maybe she'll
never be found
that's alright me Sal was smiling in the
end
I'm sure she's free of her pain I'm glad
me Sal uh-uh
well okay then that is the end I am
really thinking there might be multiple
endings here because oh my goodness oh
my goodness God that went so dark so
quickly it was all happy and fun not
really but at least I was getting a
laugh out of it and then oh oh oh yeah
highway so that was me sound and I'm
actually gonna look up to see if there
are multiple endings because if there
are I want to play them because I want
to find out like what the hell is going
on here I know there's the obvious I
could pick the other one I could pick
Toma to die but it might be something
else that I'm missing here like the the
oog only de Juarez secret password I
need to find out what that is but that
will wait until the next episode so let
me just double check here yep okay so
woah haha I will find that out soon so
thank you again everybody so much for
watching check out the other RPG horror
games that I played in the description
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
don't you put your shoulder s that's a
very good school you need to really
learn okay ladies let's get one thing
straight
this blue ugly fat dress oh okay yeah my
feeling glass where you come from what
the hell